[Music]
so
[Music]
coming up on fyi we investigate why an
increasing number of us are dieting even
though we're a healthy weight
and as the 100 cricket tournament kicks
off i got to meet some of the players to
look out for yeah i did it plus we've
got some tips on how to stay safe online
this summer
[Music]
this is fyi the weekly news show where
we bring you all the latest info on the
big stories and investigate possible
fake news so with all the extreme
weather around the world we noticed a
couple of stories doing the rounds but
we weren't sure if they were fake news
or fact so we did some digging see what
you think
[Music]
first up we found a post being shared
online claiming that it's dangerous to
feed dogs ice cubes in hot weather to
try and cool them down because eating
ice cubes actually causes them to
overheat but is that a fact
or how about these eerie pictures of
green skies that are being posted online
apparently the green skies are during a
storm in the usa but do you think
they're real or just really good photo
editing
one of these stories is fake but which
one we'll reveal all later
[Music]
so scarlet and i have been checking out
this survey which really caught our eye
it shows that an increasing number of us
are trying to lose weight by dieting
including some of us who are already a
healthy weight right so let us show you
the details so researchers at the
university of oxford have released the
results of a survey from 1997 to 2016 of
over 34 000 children in england aged 8
to 17.
over that 10-year period the number of
children using diets to slim down
increased a lot
the research suggests that one in four
of us in england are on diets while one
in seven of us are on a diet when we
don't need to be and that's really
worrying health experts
so we got a hold of dr carmen pioneers
who is one of the researchers on this
survey hi dr carmen thanks for joining
us hello thanks for inviting me i'm
delighted to be here with you today
you're a nutritionist right which means
you're an expert when it comes to eating
healthily
so is dieting dangerous when you don't
need to lose the weight for children
restricting any nutritious and healthy
food is not appropriate or necessary the
most important thing is to eat healthily
do physical activity to keep yourself
healthy and grow healthily and that
doesn't mean dieting
like heavily restricting your calories
it means just eating normally if for any
reason a young person needs help to
reach a healthy body weight then these
needs to be done
under supervision strict supervision
from a qualified expert so why do you
think so many of us want to diet when we
don't need to do you think it's because
we're under pressure to look good on
social media we need specific research
into this
and
perhaps the rise in social media culture
that promotes their thin ideal which is
something ridiculous about when you're
a young person and you think you want to
look like somebody else you know it can
really influence your behaviors but this
could definitely lead to increases in
weight dissatisfaction and
people who don't have a weight problem
trying to be losing weight and that is
worrying and we need to understand this
a bit more thank you so much for joining
us today bye thanks so much for having
me bye
remember if you are feeling down about
your body image then we've been told
that the best thing to do is talk to a
trusted adult and there's more info on
our webpage on where to go for help if
you're feeling worried just head to
first dot news forward slash fyi
we love this story this is simba the
goat and thanks to his incredibly long
ears he has become a star online and in
his home country pakistan
when he was born his ears are over 48
centimeters but they keep growing his
owner got in touch with guinness world
records he hopes that symbol will set a
new record for the longest aired goat
watch this space
[Music]
so it's summertime and we all spend a
bit more time online don't we yeah
definitely i'm guilty of it and this
month the new online safety bill was
supposed to be debated in parliament by
politicians before they vote on whether
it should happen
it's basically a set of new laws that
the government wants to bring in to
protect us from seeing harmful content
online yet the government plans big
fines for social media companies if they
don't remove upsetting material but
that's all being put on hold now until
we get a new prime minister in the
autumn which lots of people aren't happy
about
but in the meantime don't worry because
braden's got some tips on how to stay
safe online
if you're anything like me you probably
spend a lot of your time online
and let's be honest it's pretty fun
whether that's gaming chatting with your
mates or just browsing the internet
looking for some of the info i'm about
to share with you
it's super hard to imagine what life
would be like without all of our tech
but just like in the real world there
are dangers when we're online that we
need to look out for
i found some tips to keep us safe first
of all be careful what you share online
don't tell anyone your full name where
you live what school you go to or your
mobile number to find out more about
this here's online safety expert gizlane
bombusa from internet matters hi gizlane
hello braden
so why is it so important that we don't
share information about ourselves online
you've got to remember that not everyone
online is who they say they are some
people use the internet to trick young
people into sending images or
information about themselves in some
cases they even try to set up a meeting
with you which you should never agree to
so what about sending pictures and
messages to our friends is that okay
yes it is but you still have to be
careful the key thing to remember is not
to share anything that you wouldn't want
your parents or your teachers to see
remember once this image is shared
online you lose control of it
and that person that you might think is
your friend can screen grab it and share
with other people so what about if you
make a mistake and accidentally send
somebody a private picture that you then
regret
well it's important to know that if this
happens there's things that you can do
to deal with it
even though it may feel like a bit of a
laugh to send a private image to
somebody
it may leave you feeling ashamed or even
anxious if it gets out of control and
you lose control of it so the first
thing that we would say for you to do is
to get in touch with the person who you
sent the image to and ask them to delete
it if you still feel anxious
talk to a trusted adult
or you can even reach out to a charity
like childline and speak to counsellor
if the image has been posted on a social
media platform then get in touch with
the people who manage the social media
platform and ask them to remove it
thanks kisly
now i've found another thing to look out
for online scams
have you ever had an innocent looking
email asking for personal info on a link
lots of hackers use the internet to try
and trick people into handing over
personal information or passwords
they might say they're from a talent
agency and they can make you famous for
example but you should never click on
any links that ask you to share your
details the government has introduced
new laws to try and tackle this but it's
not going to be easy
we're also being told constantly by tech
companies to make sure that any
passwords we have are really difficult
for other people to guess so don't make
your password like password123
or the name of your favorite pet off you
go to those
and whenever you join anything online
make sure you read the terms and
conditions or ask your parents to take a
look to check what you're signing up for
this lane what about messaging apps or
social media sites like tick tock or
twitter is it okay for us to go on there
well most social media websites ask you
to be at least 13 to have an account on
their platform and on messaging apps
like whatsapp is actually 16 and the
reason why they have these restrictions
is so that you don't stumble across
information or messages that may not be
suitable so it's important to follow
these guidelines to stay safe online
thank you gizlane
it was a pleasure
so what have i learned well the internet
is a brilliant resource that's for
certain it can help us find out about
the world around us it can keep us in
touch with our friends and it can
entertain us i mean who doesn't love a
cat video right
we shouldn't be frightened about going
online but we just have to be careful
don't we when you think about it it's
not that complicated don't share any
private information or pictures look out
for scams asking for personal info and
talk to a parent or guardian about
anything that you see online that you're
unsure about
[Music]
for more i don't get to explain us on
the big issues that matter to you like
racism poverty and climate change just
head to our webpage first dot news
forward slash fyi
so did you guess which of these stories
was fake news or fact
[Music]
the online claims that it's dangerous to
feed dogs ice cubes in hot weather is
fake news animal charities have said
that if your dog is healthy and feeling
hot on a warm day eating ice cubes or
frozen treats is a good way of keeping
them cool
which means that these pictures of eerie
green skies during a storm in the usa
are fact
according to their national weather
service it's because water or ice
particles in the storm clouds will
scatter blue light mixed with the red
color from a sunset the water particles
in the clouds will appear to glow green
cool
[Music]
so maya what do you think of qriket i
don't know i don't really get the chance
to play it at school yeah same well if
you think qriket isn't for you then
check out our next report and you might
think again a tournament called the 100
is kicking off again this summer and
it's all about getting more of us to
watch cricket and take up the game
especially girls i decided to check it
out
this is the hundreds it's cricket but
not as you know it it's faster more
entertaining and males and females play
at the same events
who better to tell us more than players
lauren bell and maya bouchier so the 100
is a little bit different to like
standard crickets so you have 100 balls
you bowl 10 balls from each end
and you swap ends 10 times then the team
with the most runs win
[Music]
now it's my turn to give it a go with
lauren so we'll play some cricket now
scarlett so if you hold the bat like
this
with your two hands yeah perfect and
then i'll bowl at you and you should try
and hit me as hard as you can
[Music]
i've played a bit of cricket at school
but i always thought it was played by
older men and that is what the hundred
is trying to change it's introducing a
whole new generation of fans and players
seventeen-year-old alice capsi has
already had a great start to her
cricketing career thanks to the hundred
one of my kind of fondest memories is
scoring 58 lords against london spirit
some of my highlights would be obviously
winning winning 100. also winning the
opening game that was an incredible
match
oh that's class absolute class
after success with their teams at 100
last year alice maya and lauren and
other players have gone on to play for
the england national team
[Music]
some of us for example myself and like
charlie dean we've both been picked up
by england through the hundred which is
great and you know that's really
important that's how
some of the younger girls will come up
and and be able to show what they're
made of and if england are looking for
those kind of players it's it's a really
important way to to showcase that yeah i
think it's giving all young cricketers
the chance that um to be shown and be
seen and like get close to the goal of
playing international cricket
and let's face it female sport doesn't
always get the attention it deserves
it can be struggles sometimes when girls
play sports that aren't maybe
stereotypically um for women but i think
this country's just giving us a platform
to show no sport is gender-based and
there's loads of people who um like
support women playing cricket yeah oh i
did it oh sure
[Music]
great report scarlett thanks maya i
think the hundred's brilliant it shines
a whole new light on female cricketers
and speaking of women in sport you've
heard of the tour de france right yeah
it's a famous cycling race in france but
i thought it was only for men well
the big news is for the first time in 33
years the women's tour de france is back
this week that's great and it's about
time it definitely is
female cyclists have been campaigning
for years for it to return including fyi
viewer and keen cyclist ruby a couple of
years back ruby and a bunch of other
female cyclists did the same tour de
france route the men do to prove that
women can do it too
and she was out in france again this
week watching the women's race she sent
us this video
hi fyi i'm so happy that after 30 years
and a lot of campaigning the women's
tour de france is finally back and it
was so amazing to be there and watch it
i think it's so important as it can
inspire so many girls all over the world
and there were so many young girls
cheering on the riders and they probably
dreamed of being there one day and now
they can i would love to be a
professional cyclist one day and race at
the women's tour de france watching all
the women definitely inspired me even
more to train lots and be there one day
bye
thanks ruby and we've got to finish off
with a huge good luck to the england
football team yeah they played so
amazingly well and now we're through to
the finals they've smashed it it's been
a really great year for women's football
england have hosted the tournament and a
record number of tickets for the games
were sold which shows it's getting more
and more popular
we'll leave you with some of england's
highlights from the euros see you next
time
[Music]
you